you know it's great seeing everyone
the goal is to give you all the
opportunity to learn
a little bit about data science
leadership from a
accomplished data science leader each
week and from each other
we virtually have no agenda so you know
please ask questions we'll start with a
few
light topics just to get things going
don't be shy turn on your video camera
introduce yourself in the chat ask some
questions
we have people monitoring the chat so
we'll get to your question if you ask
all that said i am so happy to introduce
this week's expert he's not exactly a
stranger to our studio and
no shortage of impressive things about
him jonathan why don't you
introduce yourself and tell everyone
what you're working on in your
background
sure thank you thanks for having me rob
and uh our studio thank you for having
me
back my name is jonathan regenstein
i'm currently the head of data and
quantum mental research
at truest securities within equity
research
and before that i worked at r studio for
a little over four years uh as our
director of financial services so really
really good to be back and to see some
familiar faces again
and i can give a little background on
what we actually do
which is a question we get asked a lot
i'm sure a lot of data science teams
do we're a pretty new team
within truest securities and if if the
name
truest doesn't sound familiar we used to
be called
suntrust and bb and d and then those two
banks merged together
uh to form one big bank called truist
uh which is which i don't think is a
real world
real word but it is now um so so that
that's who we are
and yeah so so you know we're
we're formally called the data science
and engineering team
and our job really is to bring
uh what we call and this is a pretty
a pretty savvy crowd so so maybe i don't
need to use these
uh buzzwords but we say we're bringing
you know modern data science tooling
uh to the world of equity research so so
so equity research has existed at truest
for
a long time probably 30 years
and basically it's market research at
the sector level
at the individual ticker level so you
know people making recommendations on
various stocks
making recommendations on sectors and
market moves
and so we've had we have about 35
you know experts who have been doing
this for a long time
but um you know they've traditionally
lived in the world
of excel spreadsheets and excel models
and traditional market data and you know
the goal of our team is to
try to bring modern data science tooling
so things like r
and r studio but also tools like aws and
snowflake
which haven't traditionally been used at
the bank um so there's there's kind of a
tooling aspect to what we do
there's a data aspect to what we do so
um
you know the the word of alternative
data has become very hot
in the financial world which is really
just data that's not
traditional financial and market data so
you can think of like
um you know nlp-based data or things
like
app downloads uh something we work on a
lot as our just
taking our internal banking data like
credit card data
and and just mining those for insights
about the markets
so that that's kind of our role is to
take modern data science tooling take
alternative sources of data um
and bring all that stuff to the
traditional research process
which has been rolling it along really
well for the last
i don't know call it 30 years but you
know we're just trying to kind of bring
new processes and new ways of doing
things
and kind of augment what's already been
uh
you know a really strong business for
the bank
something pretty some pretty some
sources
of both um excitement but also
sometimes difficulty is that we're kind
of the first
data science team uh to arrive in our
business line
so the good thing is you know we get to
be the tip of the spear on a ton of the
cool stuff
that we're working on i mean just you
know
aws right no one was using aws before we
got here
i mean let alone putting you know our
studio server in connect on aws
so that was a far cry um so so we get to
kind of pioneer
all that stuff um and and bring these
new practices
but at the same time you know uh
sometimes um
sometimes the pioneers don't don't don't
survive that journey
so you know we're constantly fighting
the pioneers fight too you know we're
saying we want to do things differently
um and it takes a lot of time so we get
to work on really cool stuff but then we
also have to overcome
a lot of just the kind of inertia
of the way things have always been done
in the past so it's
it's pretty fun i mean it's a really
good challenge that we get to take on
and
um yeah it's been it's been really
exciting i mean
another another really cool thing about
being kind of the first data science
team to land here
is that we really started with a green
field in terms of our our coding stack
so like we
we didn't have to come kind of have
debates about you know python and julia
and r
you know we just kind of said we're
gonna we're gonna we're gonna start with
our first
um and our studio first honestly and and
just kind of go from there
so um that was another kind of lucky
thing that
uh that we had from from being again the
first data science team
um but no shortage of you know
conversations we've had to have about
well you know what i mean hey what is r
okay we've had that conversation many
times
you know what are these packages what is
crayon where are these things coming
from okay how do you manage your
packages is there a package manager
and we say yes our studio has a package
manager you know okay let's let's go
examine what that is
um you know why can't y'all just use
tableau we've had that conversation a
million times of why we prefer to use
shiny
um so we we've been just
just digging you know digging and
digging and digging
and and really trying to bring bring
workflows into the way that we want to
be doing them
um i mean we've even started using
frankly our markdown for almost
all of our reporting and just just
getting the templates
to look and feel the way people wanted
the templates to look and feel i mean
that
in itself took took quite a bit of time
because everything needs to kind of flow
into everything just be in the right
format you know to just get into
our like corporate template manager
so we've just been slowly taking on
these battles
and then of course trying to add value
along the way which is
always you know the the most important
thing
for us um so those can be small things
those can be
when i say small things that can those
that can mean like providing data that's
clean
um that that could be really valuable to
a team that
that isn't used to cleaning data um
it could be you know running models and
trying to put together some forecasts
for people so doing the kind of
cooler data science type stuff um but
but you know we've definitely learned a
a win is a win
so if it's it's going to be a simple win
from cleaning data
we go for it it's going to be a more
complex win
from you know trying to do some
forecasting we
will go for that too um i see a lot of
stuff coming in that yeah it looks like
it looks like having my shoes are coming
in
could you i'll maybe just give um give
everyone
a sense of the size of the team
that you lead and maybe just a quick
note on the the makeup of it
yeah so we're pretty small team there's
four of us right now
um so one member of the team
is just he's not officially
called a data engineer it's really funny
we
we don't have that title at the bank um
it it doesn't exist so i think he's just
called like
a research associate but but
functionally he's really a data engineer
so he does a lot of like
data harvesting you know web scraping
cleaning
getting stuff into the databases
just the way we need to be able to
access them
and then there's kind of two i guess you
could just call them more traditional
data scientists
in addition to myself who are
of varying degrees of seniority um
one of them is just recently out of
college the other one
has been out for for quite a while and
um within truist we have something
called the the data science accelerator
program
which i didn't know it existed until i
got here
but um but but this teammate went
through our data science accelerator
program which is
it's actually a pretty cool program we
can talk about it later i
i had nothing to do with instituting it
so i can
dispassionately say it's a really good
program it's uh it's like an 18-month
basically rotational program where
people you know apply as if it's going
to be a full-time job at the bank
but instead of just choosing a job they
enter the data science accelerator
which is really a chance to do three
six-month rotations around different
parts of the bank
and learn different skills and just meet
different people see different business
lines along the way
so that's where one of our teammates
came from
um i think i blanked them was there a
second part of your question rob i know
no no that's good yeah that's good and
we have plenty of questions to get to
anyway
the first one that came in right if
we're going to do this uh diplomatically
the first one that came in was
from sep and uh sep i don't know if
you're comfortable introducing yourself
and asking your question
i'll take silence as uh i'll ask the
question for you but i'll give you a
chance to answer
ask your question yeah no another
problem uh hi everybody my name is seph
i work at concert ai real world data
company
um yeah i think uh nice to meet you
jonathan
i appreciate you sharing all that
background um i think
certainly uh perhaps you triggered a lot
of people when when you were discussing
some of the
hesitancy that other other groups that
maybe are kind of
clinging on to some of this uh legacy
process or legacy technology so
uh my question for you or maybe if you
don't mind sharing some of your
strategies for
kind of working with that and maybe
overcoming some of that
yeah definitely um and it's it's
definitely ongoing so i don't want to
give the impression that we've
we've uh got it all sorted out um
so i mean for better or worse i mean
step one was really finding like a
really good partner within
uh the it org who who really you know
wanted to work with us and was really
invested in what we were doing
and and in our success um because that
that's kind of the person that
communicates
upstream not right now
yeah you look good you look great
um so yeah that that was definitely a
really important step one
and we have we talk to that person at
least once a week
usually it ends up being two or three
times a week um
it's it's just like us i don't know it's
been a really important valuable
relationship
that i mean now it's been you know over
a year that we've been
we've been working together and you know
he's
he wasn't one of those teammates that i
that i kind of referenced but he's
he's a really important part of the team
um
so that was huge because he he kind of
helps us communicate the value
proposition
and and then the the the second part of
that
i guess um
really did like trying to get
small wins along the way and frequently
um so like like i was saying we will
take small victories we we don't hold
out for when we have to
you know change the world with with a
new piece of data science
if if we can use aws
to like really quickly deliver data to
people
um you know that that's a big win for us
especially
like we'll put shiny on top of it and we
can make
data accessible to 20 people and people
get that
you know that that really resonates um
so like simple things that resonate with
people have been really really
helpful for us too but but i mean it
sounds so crazy to say this in the world
of data science but relationship
building was like
critical uh just critical to what we did
because
especially at a bank and we're a really
big company thousands of people
you know thousands of requests for new
technology
you know there's there's no way to avoid
going through all the security
uh scans and check marks that we have to
go through
so you know we just want to make sure we
have a good partner who's gonna
who's gonna help us do that um
and uh like i said i mean it's still
ongoing like we're constantly having
those conversations and refining
things uh and but also i mean i'll even
take a step even further back than that
and this is probably more relevant you
know for people who are
starting something and new um
but but but it was something i really
asked before i even
came over here which is just really make
sure that like
senior leadership was bought in to what
we were trying to do
um that was really really important
because that
when push has come to shove on a few
things we've had to really just kind of
kind of go ask someone really senior to
say
we just need to push through um and we
always explain why but sometimes we just
kind of need to push through so i guess
that that comes back to relationships
too but it's a little different from the
everyday weekly relationship we have
with our it or i guess
i guess you could really call them
functionally our devops team
um so so yeah you know showing value up
the chain has been really important for
us too and
and i mean i don't want to i should also
say you know our leadership was
already kind of invested in supportive
of this which is why we're here in the
first place
um so i think that's important also
honestly
like you know to the extent that anyone
can control this and you can't always
but but it's always
good to to be either at an organization
or in a part of the organization where
the
senior leadership is really supportive
of data science and what
and what we're doing um so that's been
you know that's been really huge thank
you yeah for sure
all right daniel are you there
yes i'm kidding can you hear me okay
yeah yeah why don't you introduce
yourself and answer your question
sure sure uh so i'm daniel obviously
i'm a lead data scientist at nestle so
uh
likewise a large corporation uh
and we've had some form of statistics
statisticians for
almost as long as nestle has been a
company but in the more recent past i
would say in the
past two to three years were trying to
modernize
uh do uh i guess what you would call
more standard data science work streams
so that includes hiring folks with new
different skills
myself included and so my question which
you
spoke to a little bit about earlier
but is really kind of thinking about uh
we tend to have
many more people that are more
[Music]
statistically minded they they can do
programming but they're
less adept at kind of doing the
productionalization steps
necessary to to get something kind of um
uh end to end and so just thinking about
if it makes more sense
to kind of upskill the folks we have
to kind of have people that can kind of
take things end to end
or to have really a smaller number of
specialized people
with maybe more knowledge on just that
final piece of
getting something through to production
yeah that's a really good question it's
it's something worth
we have been thinking about a lot um we
haven't
honestly quite got to the point that
we're um
quote-unquote putting things into
production um though we have
had to go through a lot of the process
for having our production environment
set up but but we've kind of been down a
similar journey
just for for a lot of the things we've
been doing and
i my my opinion on this i would love to
hear what other people think too
on the line um but i would i would say
that
that the end state will be a person who
has specialization in that
in that field honestly um i think
upskilling is
is important but more as a way so that
people can communicate with each other
um like that that's what we have found
that
people here are so busy that it's very
difficult to
to um to do like a thor to do a thorough
upskilling and
even in terms of just like coding and
data science you know we
what we try to do is upskill people to
the point that they kind of understand
how best to work with us and we try to
learn from them how it has to work
with them on what they want um but
ultimately
i think if it's going to be something
that technical i i would say
you'll need someone with those
specialized skills um i don't know
if anyone else has a thought on that i
would love to hear it
um that that's kind of my instinct for
where
where we ultimately end up on this
that's how we've
either one of us well i guess we'll have
to learn it but um
i would imagine well if someone really
raises their hand from our devops and
wanted to
take that on i could see that i could
see that working out
um but my instinct is it would have to
be a kind of a specialized skill i don't
know
maybe like production processes so i'm
moody howdy i run
new product development at s p global
market intelligence so
i actually do have a bunch of apps in
production
in both r and python so this is kind of
a bit
close to my heart because like as
like ours as data scientists the initial
release is always exciting right
everybody's
keyed into it and i mean i also run a
team that's about four people
once things go into production we've
learned the hard way that
we do have to kind of give that over to
some form of
devops engineering teams to sort of keep
that going and
we've had to train a lot of the skill
set and the technology side of the
equation to at least understand how to
control
some of these processes because future
enhancements need to be extended and
to be honest i can't dedicate like
people to do minor enhancements
because i have to move on to the next
thing so there is a bit of that going on
um is that is that where we're going
jonathan with it or
like like yeah i know that that sounds
right i mean i think
i think your experience is probably more
instructive since you already have apps
in production um yeah but
i think we're we're kind of getting at
the same
theme which is that time ends up being a
major limiting factor
for for how we approach whether people
are going to be upskilled or kind of
gain
you know um people are going to be
upskilled or kind of specialists are
going to be
going to be brought in um i see i mean i
i
just glanced at the chat i see kind of a
related question about you know
working with i.t which i think touches
on this and
you know how has it kind of gotten up
and running
um i mean i think
and and moody again your experience is
probably instructive in this but
you know we started out
you know a year ago and really still to
this day we still have this environment
you know step one for us was kind of
getting the permission
to just be our own devops team in the
beginning
inside of a lab environment um where we
could do things
quickly and fast and then in parallel
with that
lab environment already set up so that
we could start
doing the work we needed to do you know
in parallel to that we kind of formed
that relationship with
with i.t and then we could kind of
slowly
um build up our our dev and production
accounts
um but we had the lab environment that
we were administering ourselves that was
that kind of worked the way we wanted it
to work and then
we also kind of had a model that we
could show
to 2it along the way um so i don't know
i don't know if that tracks your
experience moody like if you started off
with kind of a lab
and and just kind of brought you know
the upskilling alongside that lab or
yeah i know exactly i mean
you know i used to have a full head of
hair before right so
you know no but it says yeah we started
like a lab right the internal lab
sort of environment and then
um we basically dockerized a lot of
basically our work into sort of restful
services
and by that nature kind of making into
production
meant that we have to kind of transition
some of those services to the software
engineering team so
like we've you know we've been lucky
like there was big
i think about four years back there was
a big drive to sort of upgrade the skill
set from like
java and cn.net
to uh or c sharp to basically python
right and then we obviously had a strong
audience and
r as well and so a lot of the software
engineers have actually
kind of the ones that do analytical work
they at least have a
background in python and they know a
little bit about r in order to be able
to maintain it
and extend features but yeah i mean it
took four years or so
to get to this point versus like like my
first
app was in 2014 and that was a batch
operation that
to this day i still maintain myself so
you know so
but i think dockerizing things and
making them much more like restful
calls makes the whole process seamless
of course you've got to have some form
of exception handling
in place but that's much easier for an
analytical software engineer or like
what used to be called a quant developer
to sort of maintain in production and
extend than
like necessarily the data scientists
who's to be honest a lot of their job is
more explorer data analysis and
building and forming a model right so
that that helped a lot like shiny
connect is kind of interesting because
once you build a very nice interface
it's very hard to sort of hand it over
to the javascript developer so i'm kind
of in the boat where i'm learning
what to do there but uh but yeah
yeah i mean it takes a bit right and
then but the key is like it does come
top down from the
cto and you know to give them the
sort of the like you know our studio
conferences i think landed has some
conferences and things
awareness awareness right so that they
know to upgrade the skill set so they're
ready to
to sort of take over that more what i
can consider more business as usual like
version 1.0 your guys have involved
version you know 1.1 1.2 1.5
it's the software engineers really doing
the work right so
yeah and i think i mean depending on
what type of work everyone's in you know
moody mentioned like a four-year
process and we're about a year into our
process and i can envision it being
about a four-year process
to actually get there um so you know big
big financial orgs it just things just
take
time to to get to this point um so i'm
sure
it kind of depends on what type of org
people are
are sitting inside of um
there's a there's a question from uh
around language mandates from
uh ashish if uh sorry if i mispronounce
your name if you wanna
ask your question with some context uh
feel free
yeah uh thanks robert uh amashish i'm
working as a senior data scientist at
medicine petroleum corporation um
so uh jonathan you were talking about
you were deciding on
whether to use python julia or r and
then you start with r
this kind of a similar story we started
our data science team about six years
ago with two data scientists one of them
were using r and one of them were using
python and um as we grew the team
over the years now we have about 15 data
scientists and
now the scale is tilted towards python
and we have about
more than 10 people using python and
about couple of them
using our and part of the reason i'm
asking this question is we didn't want
to
you know contain the creativity or
talent pool
that we can avail uh by restricting the
use of one language versus other but it
seems like just there is much more
talent or availability of python
resources and also
at the same time as moody and you were
talking about we are also in a
multi-year process of setting up
uh platforms environment to you know
operationalize
and it seems like uh like we are trying
to set up azure
and we have looked into some other as
well
including data robot and everything
seems like r
is getting like a second class um
citizen
uh treatment from most of them so
how do you manage that i mean we also
have r studio connect
which can do python and jupyter notebook
publication and operational appreciation
but it doesn't seem to be going very uh
smoothly at least with us so how do you
manage that or what kind of challenges
you see in that direction
yeah so i mean again my my experience
might be a little bit
different i mean you know i i kind of
knew
i was gonna say from day one but really
like day zero that this was gonna be an
art based team
you know um and because that that that's
what i think is the best tool for
for what we do and we're a very research
intensive
shop um and i i think r is like a
superior tool chain just for
for research but we do sit next to
kind of the quant development team or i
should say we will sit next to them when
we're back in the office right now we
just have a lot of zoom calls with them
and they're they're the team of pretty
pretty heavy python users
and um they haven't really found a great
environment for what they do so they are
probably going to end up just
cloning um our
our production environment and just
using it as a python production
environment
using the rstudio tool chain um so we we
haven't found it
and that'll again that's going to be
like six months from now um
because things go so slowly um so so i
didn't really
we didn't hit a lot of those initial
hurdles of r versus python
because we kind of knew from day one
that this was going to be an r based
team
the talent pool has actually been a
pretty interesting
experience for us so like i said we have
this internal data science accelerator
and i definitely would say
that that if there's 20 candidates
per rotation you know
all of them will have you know python uh
on their resume it's a very very
ubiquitous language
but then we will find a handful maybe
four or five
who are like really passionate about
about
r you know and they like that they're
they're
excited about it they're fired up about
it so we've been able to find like super
high quality
people even though maybe there's there's
fewer of them
and i don't know it's actually been kind
of an interesting experience
because it's almost gotten to the point
now that we we just tell the people who
are on the program
listen if there's any really really
passionate our coders out there just
send them our way
um you know so there's probably 15
teams competing for all the python
coders and then there's like
us and one other team competing for the
r coders um so
we kind of get the uh you know the cream
of the crop for our coders
how much does the yeah how much does it
how much does the decision matter
uh the decision about about what uh
language oh um
how much does it matter yeah
yeah uh well let's see what do you mean
by how much does it matter
uh like how much would it impact your
team to be
functioning in python uh
well let's see here it would impact us
well i don't think it would impact it
wouldn't impact the end results that we
could
deliver i guess at the end of the day i
mean i kind of feel like
there's probably really skilled python
coders who can do what we do and
are um i wouldn't be one of them i can
tell you that
so that would that would probably be the
uh
the sign that i'm back back to the r
world somewhere
i mean i that being said
especially for what what we are our end
product
is research reports and typically
visualizations so that's usually what we
are building
um so from that sense i actually don't
know if i don't know if there's a huge
population of python coders who
really want to dig into what we're
trying to do
and spend as much time as we do you know
trying to build
like reproducible charts and and things
like that
um and also like i said
we use our markdown for all of our
reporting um
because we just think it's the best
templating tool out there
obviously you can you can use python
within our markdown so that would be
a possibility i guess i don't know
enough about the python
world to say whether there's some um
equivalent or markdown out there i mean
every once in a while i'll see on
twitter someone will say hey this is
just like our markdown but for python
but
but then other people are like man not
really it's not really like our workout
for python
um but i'm not i'm not a python person
so
for what we do uh are as
are as the superior choice um then i
guess
you know i wouldn't be here doing it if
i i didn't think that so
um and shiny has actually also been
really really useful for us
because i would say the the kind of
blocking and tackling
of what we do which a lot of people
really just want clean data
a lot of times we're just building shiny
front ends to sql databases so that
people can like
intuitively sift through data see some
interesting charts
possibly download those charts or just
download the raw data behind them
so we've found shiny to be like really
useful for that again i'm
i'm sure there's python coders out there
who could build the same
in python um but but shiny works
beautifully for us
well there was a the next question was
from travis and it touches on python a
little bit travis i don't know if you
want to
hop on and ask your question yeah
hi i'm travis um i'm a data scientist at
parsons corporation
so i've been kind of like the only data
scientist on my team
recently there's some other team members
who
well i should first say we recently got
our studio workbench
and then i've been tasked with also
getting python up and running
and so i'm wondering um
how much sense it makes to really commit
to using reticulate and python within
our studio
or should i just you know use like
jupiter lab or something on
on that server to keep it separate i've
had some issues
with like our firewalls getting things
downloaded
like miniconda and that sort of thing
yeah so we're we're actually exploring
both paths right now
um both reticulate and jupiter labs for
like i said there's a quant team that
sits next to us that's just a pure
python team
um and they're they're not really going
to be using any
any r um
just from my experience with with them
and what they've gravitated towards
they're not huge fans of jupiter they
kind of like are marked down better
so as long as the the package management
is not too painful though i think
they're used to it being
a little bit painful which is just kind
of
part of the deal
they've had a better experience when
we've just tested things out with our
markdown and reticulate
honestly but but this is really just
like
you know an end of one they're not huge
fans of jupiter
so i i found some again i'd love to hear
what other people
think about this that you know hard
really experienced maybe hardcore
python coders they're often lukewarm on
jupiter i don't know they like it but
they're not really that fired up about
it
and the reporting capabilities in our
markdown usually
just people like those so much better
but we have to do a lot of documenting
and a lot of reporting
my team does and their team does too
because they're doing a lot of a lot of
trading
and they want to have a nice uh i don't
know a nice record of what's been going
on
um so that's the route we're planning to
take is
our markdown reticulate route with that
team
but again that's more driven by their
their preference which
isn't really that skewed towards jupiter
notebook
and in fact i would say if if they were
already in love with jupiter
that you know this would be kind of a
nice to have but they haven't found a
great
python environment yet um and i think
that
so they're kind of intrigued that
there's something new out there
um but yeah the package management is is
is the thing if that can be solved for
for the python guys i
i think they'll be psyched but that's as
far as we've gone with that
we've done a few kind of demos of you
know here's how our studio workbench
works
here's the jupiter hooks um here's all
our markdown and reticulate work and
here's how we can publish both up to
connect
and the the arm marked down via
reticulate i think it was just
it was just a newer a newer fancier tool
also you know like they've seen jupiter
labs a million times
and have already kind of made the
decision that it's not necessarily the
tooling they want
um but that again that's just i don't
know how generalizable that is that's
really just my experience with
with one team of python coders that i
sit next to
that makes sense thank you sure
all right eric are you there sure
yeah welcome back yeah thanks yeah great
to be back and
um great discussion jonathan i'm really
commiserating a lot with what you're
talking about
i work in pharma so we have a very
large org lots of different groups that
are doing statistical data science and
working with i.t quite a bit and
we are adventuring in somewhat new
frontier
um with at least from my to my group
we're augmenting a lot of the shiny apps
and
our pipelines are developing with aws
and the various services within it and
i'm kind of
like the pioneer in my immediate group
on a lot of this i'm trying to
first of all learn the best ways to do
it myself and also be able to
empower my teammates to get up and
running very quickly so i didn't know
in your experience how have you been
kind of
making sure that your data scientists on
your team
is able to leverage these technologies
very well i don't know if you have any
advice about that yeah i mean
this this kind of goes back to the kind
of lab versus production environment
so we were able to to get a lab
environment set up for
us where we had a lot of freedom in aws
um i mean it's still behind our vpn it's
totally locked down
like you can only get to it you know
from behind our firewalls etc
but within that we kind of got some
freedom there and then
we just started spinning up our you know
a couple of servers and we kind of built
our studio server and and
and we built a couple of databases in
awls awl ourselves
and it was really helpful for us
to learn exactly what we needed um and
and
we've been doing that for a year now and
now that we're setting up a proper like
prod and dev environment
and we can kind of show it to to our rit
team and tell them to just
basically clone it so it has kind of a
double payoff like we got to learn the
skills
and then they get to clone it we really
just learned about
it by following through the aws docs and
then doing some of their trainings
um i mean so
one person here kind of already knew how
to do all this stuff on aws
the biggest roadblock we hit was
honestly uh
git and gitlab and github those were not
blessed
technologies here so so we had to
use uh aws's code commit which was
um i'm i'm convinced we were the only
team in the world
using it because i couldn't find any
documentation on it
stack overflow anywhere um but we we
eventually got gitlab
um i shouldn't say we got a blessed we
found another team that had already
brought it into the enterprise and then
we were able to kind of hook into that
so so now we're using
um we're using git lab for our
for all of our versioning but that that
was a big roadblock
for us um i mean
but the i think the real key was just
was
we needed an environment where we could
learn and kind of
get things set up the way we wanted them
so getting
somehow getting the freedom to have that
lab set up you know
for us it was it was we really just kind
of told the truth
which was you know if if we have to wait
for the dev environment it's going to be
six months before we can do anything
which which was true i mean that was the
that was the actual timing it would have
been
um and that that would have been really
we just would have been sitting around
for
for six months so we we needed the lab
set up
um and when they we were able to get
that
get that done but and then from there we
we could kind of play around and learn
how we wanted things set up
but getting the lab set up was was
critical
yeah that uh was not the most uh
pleasant
uh experience for me to get my kind of
current environment set up for our
immediate group
other it groups kind of had their own
aws like what i'll call partition and
i was given access to one of them but
then i was like well i can't really do
stuff on there and mix it up with the
stuff i'm doing in my group so i finally
got that set up
and now it's still have to go through a
lot of process to get like the sub
services spun up like
database and s3 and all that fun stuff
once it's up there i'm
experimenting with things but yeah
that's just uh i don't think anybody's
ever had a smooth time with that
yeah no it it it wasn't so like
once we got the permissions it wasn't so
bad um
but uh the the journey continues i would
say
because we like i said we still have
more than once a week
calls with it and devops just it's like
it's like the one
weekly call that you know we we have to
have
uh honestly just to keep things rolling
in the right direction
yeah very similar for us yeah great
insights yeah thank you yeah
sure we you touched on it just now a
little bit uh
and you i think you answered the next
question at least in the queue allen's
question around i
t but i do want to give it the
opportunity uh to to get the
the proper spotlight so alan if you want
to
ask your question with a little bit more
context
yeah sure um i think you've really been
speaking to it pretty
pretty well um i guess i think probably
i'm sitting here
feeling sympathy and empathy about a
common scenario where
we've we we need lots of stuff from i.t
i.t has very limited resources
and often our interests don't
necessarily
align in a nice way and so we have a
pretty frequent negotiation of
what can we get support for what's kind
of inbounds from a like enterprise
architecture perspective where we tend
to be pretty
potentially ahead of where it is ready
to support
and so i guess curious is pushing the
question a little bit have you
have you had to have those conversations
where you're bringing stuff to it
that they're really not ready to support
yet and they have concerns about
and you know for sure having you know
leadership uh champions who can help
in those conversations seems to be
really critical
it's one of those places that as as my
team and as our function
tries to scale up we're going to need
more of that official support
where to date we've got enough kind of
tacit support that we can get things
done
but in the long term we're going to need
to carve out like this is our set of
space
and it supports us in a particular way
um and uh and we have lots of lots of
back and forth about that about
who owns what who should own what what's
appropriate to support at given times
um so it sounds like it's a it's a
common dilemma so
at least at least we're not alone in
that i guess
yeah not for sure um yeah i would say
you're definitely not alone
in that struggle um yeah i mean one
thing we were able to
[Music]
to i guess negotiate or just kind of get
squared away up front was that
was that we kind of said okay once we
get this lab environment
set up you know we're happy to migrate
to a fully managed account by it if they
want to own it
but we kind of said like we're not
migrating until
you know we've confirmed that it works
because we can't just have everything
break on us
so i guess we've kind of proceeded in
phases like get the lab environment
get it producing value for the business
and then say well we can't just
drop this you know until there's
something else viable in place
um so yeah you just kind of ladder up as
you go
i think we've we've experienced
something similar where we can we can
demonstrate that we're
that we're providing real value
therefore you know we sort of elbowed
our way into that space
and and now we have some value that we
can provide uh
if you if you cut us off it will it will
have
impact um but but it's real um
it's a real organizational kind of
challenge and even political sort of
dilemma sometimes around
you know being in this space and and who
has kind of domain control over
over decisions there um has been
beyond all of the technical and
methodological stuff that we that we
really like to do
that's the organizational part that that
for us
for me is is just an ongoing challenge
yeah
were you um i mean were you kind of
starting from
you know like for you and your team was
this something you were kind of starting
anew
or were you trying to take something
existing in a new direction
a little bit of both we've had some
independent capability that we were able
to bring up because
we knew at the time that there was no
support more broadly in our enterprise
to bring up the capability we needed so
we sort of stood up our
you know stack of tools pretty
independently
but we realized that as we grow we're
going to need more support so that we
can focus on the things that we think
as a function we provide lots of unique
value
and we want to be able to rely on on i.t
or other functions for the things
that are are less unique so you know
we need them to handle configuring
single sign-on
working with networking doing firewall
doing security
um and we focus on the things that that
we that we think
we're you know more specialized and and
and good at
um but they're a really limited resource
and they have lots and lots of things
drawing on their
on their focus so you know it's a
constant
kind of negotiation yeah
jonathan how far out are you planning
things with it so you have a weekly call
are you talking to them about things
going on three months from now six
months from now a year from now
uh not i wouldn't say a year from now
that's that's that's kind of way too far
out yeah um
yeah hypothetically yeah because if if
if it's on the calendar for
a year from now that means realistically
it's probably
two years away um but yeah
i would say three to six months because
that's three to six months is really
just how long it takes
to too i don't want to say get anything
done but to have like a start
to finish new implementation
like done and blessed and handed off
it's three to six months
that even things that seem you know
simple
like there are so many stakeholders
involved especially i mean we're
we're part of a bank so we always have a
security layer that has to bless
everything
that we're doing so i mean
we almost don't want to go too far
beyond three to six months
um now that i think about it there
probably is
one or two things on the calendar that's
like in a year we need to have this
stood up
um and that that that mostly relates to
kind of onboarding the python team that
sits next to us
because that kind of can't start until
our environment is like fully built out
and then since they're they're a
different team there's like a different
security
layer that has to to go into that um
so yeah three to six months is where we
try to keep things
fantastic thank you ben are you still
there
i see that i i think i see your name i
have your question i at least wanted to
give you a chance to ask it so the
question uh
from ben do you have any thoughts on how
to be a data science champion within a
large organization
uh i have a lot of thoughts about it
but um maybe the truncated version yeah
yeah yeah um i mean so the
the the first thing that was
pretty that we did was we tried to seek
out other people who wanted to champion
this stuff
like the more people you know that we
kind of found you know like-minded
uh people up and down the chain you know
like
very junior people and very senior
people too who who really wanted to
champion this
um so that that was definitely step one
um was finding other people
and then that was how we found this data
science accelerator that we
we didn't know existed um so if anyone's
at an org
and you don't have a data science
accelerator program it's been super
successful at truest
um so so happy to talk to more people
about
what what we've seen work well there
that originated in like the enterprise
data organization
other than that i mean it's been a ton
of communicating
uh and and
most of what we're communicating is not
really data science
it's more the value like the value
proposition of what we're doing
and why we're doing it very very we
always have
one slide on like our our technology
stack
that encompasses you know our studio aws
snowflake
uh data data vendors that's all kind of
put onto one
one slide of like a 10 slide deck
so other than that we're always just
talking about
the value we're bringing how it's going
to help non-data scientists that's like
a huge theme
at the bank you know it's always about
it's always about lifting up teammates
you know so if data science can help
enhance other people's work that's
always like
something people are very very
supportive of uh
upskilling do you know a lot of people
are interested in that but
but it's a lot of work to help upskill
people but if
if you can find people who are willing
to take on that work
i think it's that's a big win also but
that's really a lot of work
it's very time consuming um especially
i mean at a big organization that's been
like a nine month project
just kind of getting on the the training
calendar of okay we want to start up
skilling people on data science
teaching people about r et cetera
you know creating the content and doing
it that's like the easy part
getting it getting it on the docket has
been the hard part but
but uh i i definitely think
that trying to position data science
as something that helps other people has
been really important for us
just because again there's there's some
hesitancy about data science there's
some hesitancy about
this new thing this new technology that
could kind of take over
what other people are doing so
yeah i think that that's been helpful
too
um so that was a
positioning data science is something
that helps other people and finding
other
like other little pockets of data
science champions has has been
has been a good way for us to approach
things um
and help us figure out who we need to
talk to about different initiatives
yeah we've done this uh you know this is
our fifth time doing this now and each
time communication has
come up as a school a core skill set or
you know a core activity
you know just food for thought
i want to make sure that we get all the
questions that were asked in before the
time we don't have a hard stop now
jonathan obviously uh
you know we're we're abiding to your
schedule but we don't have a hard stop
but for anyone who needs to jump i want
to make sure that we get to the
questions in the audience
the final one that i have and please
continue asking questions but the final
one that i at least have on the list
right now is
from alejandro uh if you're still there
i'll give you a second to join and
ask your question and introduce yourself
yes thank you very much
hi everybody i'm alejandro from italy
i work for a kind of data-driven company
it's called chattabat
we have this like problem with
management
in the sense that we sell products and
we make products that
are deeply statistical models
machine learning models data science
pipelines
ad hoc projects and i feel that we have
this problem with
project management this senior managers
handle things in the typical
project management way and on the other
hand
i have some support from it
with more software development kind of
management
and i feel that neither the two words
fit with the data science uh
kind of projects how do you handle this
i i
from what i heard you have more or less
this uh
approach of data science not software
development only
thank you
um yeah so yeah that that's a really
good question it's
it's that was actually strangely enough
another thing that i
didn't really anticipate being a
challenge here
um but it was definitely something we
had to overcome or i shouldn't say
overcome was more just
there was no kind of infrastructure in
place and there wasn't even like an
informal
way of doing things around that i would
definitely want to open this up to other
people who i'm sure have have plenty of
experience with this but for
for us um we've taken a
yeah a very data sciencey approach and
we've just leaned really heavily on
on gitlab honestly so that that was a
that was honestly a big step forward for
us there there really was no there
wasn't even version
control when we got here um we had to
kind of
bring that in and then
once we were able to get version control
blessed and have it be part of
part of what we did we we really just
run all of our workflows
uh around version control in gitlab and
we're a very small team there's there's
only four of us um
so and then we have kind of autonomy in
the way that we do things
so we just kind of run things
honestly through get lab and we have our
own we have our
own i guess you could call it project
management but really it's just kind of
a project workflow that
the four of us use and you know
as we add more you know more members to
the team
we'll refine that workflow and everyone
will kind of we'll kind of use it from
there
so i mean i guess this was an area we
got
maybe a little bit lucky we got to kind
of start from ground zero
and we didn't really need to rewrite any
rules
um i don't know if anyone else has had
experience where they've had to kind of
try to change a traditional workflow but
for us
that was you know just
we have our own workflow it's all
centered around around git
and that's been working for us so far
i'll let that breathe if anyone wants to
hop in
give it a few seconds
i mean like the project management side
i mean i i know what you mean it's
tricky right because like at the end of
the day you're trying to target
deliverable and some of the early
pieces you're kind of exploring so you
don't actually know
what you would actually end up
developing to hit that deliverable in
production i mean
i mean i struggle on the explorative
data side i mean you might have a
bit of a different use case because
you're selling that product immediately
it's tricky like um so i tend to like do
small iterations and show
value early and then say hey you know
what the next iteration
we're gonna have to try something
completely different and here you go
um we kind of buffer a lot early on on
the
on the like the model design piece
um and then because implementation
typically after that is quite quick
and then project managers typically
understand that kind of
that that piece but yeah it's it's tough
right because you don't have something
prescriptive that you're gonna implement
which is what most project managers are
used to you know
um so yeah exactly uh
actually well thanks for the answers
both of you
we have this like different languages or
um objectives uh that
managers want concrete things and you
say okay we've made lots of pro
progress in the model fine-tuning or in
the exploratory or whatever
and okay so it is ready
what percent of ready i don't know we
are
making progress yeah yeah
it's tough i i i like i buffer so i do
small iterations and then after like
three or four
i would assume that we basically have
something close that can be prescriptive
but like the last one is typically
running over a historical time period to
make sure that
if we were to actually implement this in
production on a wider scale it will run
but the first
three or so are on a much smaller sample
size i mean it's look it's not
bulletproof
like uh you know because the folks are
used to
much more of a prescriptive style of
implementation right so
yeah thank you very much i will try
buffering a little bit more thanks
alejandra
one thing i ran into with um like scrum
is an agile is people don't seem to
remember
what agile is supposed to mean they make
they take it as more of a we have
stand-ups and we have specific tasks so
having those conversations has helped
somewhat
be like well the the purpose of agile is
to allow
iteration and we don't always know
because it's exploratory
data science is very different from your
regular computer science and product
development
i completely agree uh that's why i i
don't feel when they propose
the agile or scrum uh
to fit in because it's kind of okay but
i cannot iterate this way or my task was
this one but
now i'm over there so yeah it's it's
kind of tricky
that's why my question was is there
a an alternative to typical project
management and
scrum or agile but i i feel
we are on the same boat everybody thanks
all right to to finalize the the formal
questioning again we don't have a hard
stop but people tend to
you know ease out but please please stay
on um
jonathan one question we've been asking
uh
our our experts is what what would you
recommend
focusing on for data science teams or
data science leaders
you know over the next arbitrary sort of
you know
number of days a year uh to you know to
to set themselves up for success
yeah so i mean i i guess i'm repeating
myself a little bit but
but for for us at the bank
it's it's it's all about like the cross
functionality
that that we're working on right now um
so you know in a year we we probably
won't be able to
to kind of hide behind the fact that
we're a new team
and we need to run lean and we need to
have time to do stuff
so like our enterprise data organization
rit team
even things like our recruiters you know
in the talent pipeline like
like all those things are going to
basically become little
little parts of what we do so i think
for
for us you know that's the next step
over the next year
is strengthening all that stuff
you know i think we've we're a year in
and we've reached the point
that everyone gets what we're doing they
kind of see the value in what we're
doing
um but for long-term success i think the
cross-functional relationships
are going to be a big focus um
which is a lot of time there's a lot of
meetings
um so it's a lot a lot of time with
hands-off keyboards
which um is is just like a different
phase
of what we're doing other than that i
mean
we're since we're in the finance world
which is probably totally different than
you know than most other places um
but yeah we're really focused on
setting up a good data lake like we
don't real
that's a big i shouldn't even say data
lake database like a good database
um that that's another big a big focus
for us over the next year
which i'm sure most people on this call
are already
already well beyond that phase but but
we're kind of building everything from
scratch
do you have any tips for for folks who
i'm sorry if i cut you off do you have
any tips for for folks who are
who may not be running the team or the
head of the department to become better
across
functionally
uh i mean better cross-functionally
yeah i mean let's see i'm trying to
think it's a really good question
um i mean there's
at least for us there's no shortage of
of tasks that need to be done in that
area
and it's very very time consuming and i
find
honestly i find most data scientists
don't want to do it
it's not really why anyone would say
they want to be a data scientist
right so it's not considered the
you know the the fun stuff of data
science you know
no one's really going to ask about what
you're actually working on
um so i guess
i would just say you know do it put your
hand up and do it and get involved in
those conversations
um i don't know moody you might have
some some thoughts on this i'm sure
you've had a lot of
a lot of cross-functional work i find
most people just don't want to do it
because it's really not
like data science like you mean
cross-functional like working
trying to like say move up the
organization is that what you mean
no no well so what i mean more is that
you know i spend as much time
talking to our enterprise data
organization
as i do the people who are like
technically on my team
oh i see and i spend as much time
talking to it who again there's
technically a separate team
um from than actually like talking
i'm not talking about data science with
them yeah i'm talking about the
infrastructure we need and things like
that
it if you're not you know you or
jonathan right if you're someone more
more junior uh how would you go about
that
yeah like so like so to like
like i think jonathan and i are probably
pretty similar in that sense
i think you you actually said it earlier
jonathan resonates what you said
talk about the value not how to get
there right like i never talk about like
to the business
we talk about like a product being
released or some revenue potential
like to the folks who are paying it and
we're not really talking about our
python or
even a model at that point it's just the
fact that there is some
opportunity that we're going to go after
and the fastest way to go after that
is this right and this is sort of
how we will take the data and then
combine it and then push it out
and then you kind of are committed to
some time frame so the business
will understand that right
now on the other side when you like
to talk to the sort of the tech and
devops i think maybe i'm a bit
lucky in a way because they've kind of
gone warm to the whole like our python
like environment like we also use aws
and then we can kind of
build against a more i guess a more
rigorous like
um source safe basically source code
management and stuff
now yeah like jonathan i guess to your
point like yeah when you sort of align
with those
folks um this conversation is not about
data science for us about the products
and then
you know can we improve for example
indexing on some of our databases
to enhance like in a pull for a job
right or trying to look at the data lake
we have like
we have the opposite problem i think we
have a lot of data links
so like how do you improve that because
the quality of the content coming in
needs to kind of
get better and that's a much trickier
discussion because obviously
there's a processes on that side to get
the data in and push it out
so yeah you almost never talk about
funny enough you almost never really
talk about like
the cool stuff you've done like which is
the model piece
uh until like you've kind of documented
it and you're
for me if you're on sales call if i'm
selling to jonathan for example i talk
about the model piece
but that's like you know but that's
really
that's it um yeah you kind of have to be
to move up i guess
or to talk you have to have speak
different languages one data one
software engineering and one business
domain
but to sell yourself to get a project
and move up your talking business
100 percent of the time you know
business and cost
all right so jonathan where where can
people uh find you
on the internet or get in contact with
you um
you can you can always find me on
linkedin i'm i'm uh
i'm constantly posting little r snippets
on there
so yeah um yeah that's the best place to
to connect with me
and um feel free to reach out anytime
if anyone wants to talk about our
finance uh et cetera
that's what we do and shameless uh
shameless plug for you you've uh i think
you've written a book
yeah yeah i mean my i uh i wrote a book
a long time ago
uh called reproducible finance with r so
it's been three years now
originated as a series of blog posts on
our views
uh so thank you joe rickard if you're on
this call but if you're not
you'll see the recording um so yeah that
was that was a long time ago but um
we might we might crank out another book
this year to kind of update some code
and talk more about the macro
economy but yeah
looking forward to connecting with
everyone
fantastic yeah um
let me real quick just for anyone who
wants to put your linkedin profile in
the chat
um and while i while i do that we we do
these every
if this is your first time joining we do
these every thursday at noon the zoom
length is always the same
so maybe exciting news is we're working
now on just getting the recording sort
of uploaded in full to
to our youtube channel so folks can can
go back and
watch them that that due date or we're
trying to be able to do that sometime
within the next few weeks
but i put in jonathan's linkedin profile
in the chat um but yeah
thank you so much jonathan for joining
us and dropping some knowledge
sure my pleasure thanks everyone and
thank you moody for the
significant contributions thank you
moody
take care thank you all right thank you
very much hopefully see everyone
next thursday
you